hello everyone I hope you all had an
excellent weekend and you're ready to
continue the coverage of the 2013
candidates tournament it's a game from
Round seven Magnus Carlsen vs. team
ultra job of course and is still in the
lead with levin aragon and her job of
definitely definitely you know wants to
say something about that and it's very
interesting as I've said in my previous
video the pleasures of playing three
runs then there's arrested and three
runs then the rest day than the three
runs then there's a rest day and as this
is round seven there was a rest day
after round six so as it usually is in
tournaments after players you know
really get rested and then either you
will see fireworks on all of the boards
or you will see a very slow day you know
players are even though they came here
to play chess they enjoyed resting so
much that they are resting when they
should you know be playing some some
good chess so it's a who knows which of
these scenarios happened in round 7 to
figure that out we have to we have to
check out some games and before we see
the game we do have some photos of this
round so here we have a photo cross and
vs. or a job of as you can see the the
situation is very intense even before
the first move was even made here
another photo from a different
perspective also you can see that the
players are very focused Carson is
staring at the board it's like he
doesn't know what move he will make and
the players played a very interesting
variation and the entire game is very
interesting so let's check it out Carson
opens with E 4 we have c5 the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
now comes Bishop to b5 the rosolie more
attack sometimes called the Dinesh
Medina of rosalie more attack as a
Russian Desmond Dean of did use this
quite often against the knight c6
Sicilian and he produced some brilliant
victories in this line and it's very
interesting we don't have a photo of
this moment when Bishop to b5 was played
and it's very interesting here you can
see Carson making the Bishop to b5 move
and for some reason raja baath already
has his hand in the air it's like he
knows what move he's going to make next
and he wants to show Carson that he is
definitely prepared for the Bishop to b5
variation or it could be that he's just
immediately going for his pen to write
down cousins move so a very interesting
turn of events
so after Bishop to b5 we have e six
Bishop captures on c6 b captures on c6
and here Carlson goes for B 3 so black's
pawn structure is somewhat crippled
cross in place b3 he's ready to develop
the bishop on B to the b3 pawn will
nullify the rooks influence on the B
file and it's a pretty standard trade
off White's pawn structure is somewhat
better but black does have the bishop
pair so you know whatever you prefer
we have d6 and castles nice - e7 and
immediately 5 and here you could push
something like d5 and like does have a
strong center but this a 5 pawn white
has is very annoying it really has a lot
of influence on blacks position so after
a 5 nights to g6 piling up on the e5
pawn and here Carlson captures eek a
person d6 Bishop captures and Knight to
c3 we have E 5 for the moment kind of
blocking his own Bishop on d6 but he
does he doesn't want to activate the
light square Bishop rook to e1 we have
castles and now comes b3 and a job of
goes for f5 it's very interesting maybe
for those of you who who are maybe new
to chess because this is something I
encounter quite often when playing
against the newer players I move like
Bishop to g4 is something you don't want
to do before actually thinking about it
as there is a knight on g6 it doesn't
matter if it's a knight or anything else
or even if it's a pawn on g6 some
players do play this move and then after
you play h3 they didn't really think
what they will do with the bishop so now
you kind of have to move the back you
can't go here because then g4 will trap
it and you don't have to trade it or you
want to just go back so if this is the
situation you don't want to play a move
like that unless you really want to
trade this Bishop for a knight so just
just putting it out there so f5 buy a
job of Bishop to e3
as the c5 and the c6 bones are somewhat
weak
will will you know place his pieces and
an ideal squares to attack those
weaknesses Bishop to e6 now comes Knight
to a4 piling up on the c5 pawn Queen to
e7 defending and now see for now locking
down those pawns rook to b8 we have
Queen to e2 Bishop to see it and now
transferring the bishop all the way to
the Queen side and now comes Queen to e3
Queen to e3 is a very forward way of
dealing with things
now Carson is has a triple attack on the
c5 pawn and he's basically forcing a job
of to push f4 to move the Queen away
from here and this is exactly exactly
what her job of place but there was a
very interesting variation here as the
c5 pawn is I mean those double bonds
aren't really doing all that much and
you know they're not really going to be
useful in the endgame so how about me
maybe you can give up some of those
points to increase your activity on the
Kings side as you do have two very nice
bishops if you can somehow pull those
pawns
activate the bishops and you know bring
the Queen there it could get very ugly
for white so what about a move like
Knight to h4 Knight 2 H 4 is a very
interesting move for example
now black is seemingly giving up d5 pawn
but if you capture this then you get
Knight captures on g2 it's a very
unpleasant move for white you're
attacking his rock on e1 and Queen on e3
so after King captures now you push f4
and now the Queen still has to defend
the night as the knight is attacked by
both the bishop and the Queen so after
Queenie for Bishop to a5 you kick away
the Queen Queen e2 and now comes Queen
to h4 and white is up a piece but black
has a very very nasty attack f3
now comes Bishop captures and after
Queen captures it's Bishop to h3 and
white white is completely lost here kim
jiwon and now Rock to d8 there's no
defense if you move the Queen Rock
capture sandy won both the rook and the
Queen are attacking the rook so you
don't have to give up the Queen here or
you're just losing the game so a very
interesting variation but unfortunately
after night here you don't have the
white
have to capture on e5 of course he can
simply capture and then after Queen
captures it would be it would be a very
double-edged position still white white
still has play here on the Queen side he
can start gobbling up those pawns but
black will be able to start pushing here
and maybe create some activity but as
interesting as it is a Java goes for f4
immediately counters this threat of of
c5 pawn being attacked we have Queen to
e4 and now comes King to h8 and now rook
a to D 1 by Carlsen here cross and says
that he did think about h3 but then then
he saw that rook to f5 wasn't really
possible but her job of thought that
rook to f5 was possible this is
something they discussed in in an
interview after the game
what Carson saw unroped to f5 if you
wanted to transfer the rook also into
the attack across and so d4 here and now
if see pawn captures then you can
exchange here and then the d5 pawn
becomes weak or if you play it captures
here then Carson saw Queen captures rook
on f5 Bishop captures and rook captures
Queen captures captures and then after
captures captures it would it would be a
pretty equal ending where black would
have a bishop against the night and it's
it's very hard to say would those points
here be be an advantage or a weakness
for black but he didn't really he didn't
really think think too much about it so
he played rook a to d1 Bishop to g4 we
have rook to d2 and now comes Bishop
captures on f3 Queen captures in the
knight to h4 so a very very nice attack
by our job of on the Kings side Queen to
e4 and now comes f3 and Carson saw all
of this and he prepared something very
nice for a job of g3 attacking the
knight Knight to g2 and now as the rock
on e1 is attacked across and ignores
this and he plays Knight to c3
I preparing to activate his pieces again
and Carson's idea is that he has a very
nice setup here and on the Queen side as
black does have DS
nasty doubled pawns even if he gives up
the exchange his rock isn't all that
useful and this night is a monster night
so he doesn't mind trading this Queen
2e6 first her job of first tries to
improve the position and now comes
Knight rook to e3
instead of rook to e3 our job says that
he didn't consider something like King -
h1 and this kinda reminds me of the time
macaque tell hallucinate it in his game
against Botvinnik then our job says he
saw Queen to h3 and after look the g1 he
thought that maybe cousin would want to
give up the exchange this way to get rid
of this Knight but then he saw that
after rook f6 he prepares to bring the
rook into the game then he thought what
about rook captures on g2 and then if
pawn captures then Queen will capture
but then he saw oh wait a minute
Queen captures and g2 is checkmate so
that was kind of funny when he said that
in an interview and he said yeah I mean
even and even at this level a player's
can overlook a mate in one if you're
interested in watching the entire
interview after the game I will put a
link to the article in the description
below as as we do have it after every
run so be sure to check it out rook to
e3 by Carlsen now piling up on that f3
pawn and now he forces a job to capture
the rook so Knight captures we have pawn
captures and here is kind of the
critical moment in the game here there's
a lot a lot of things to calculate and
it's only moved 25 so you're not even
close to reaching time control you still
have to make 15 moves and here are the
best the best idea how to continue this
attack is something like Bishop to e7
Bishop to e7
you know activate your rooks maybe go h5
bring the rook into the game and just
try and increase pressure the reason a
job of decided not to do something like
this he didn't he didn't like this nice
to d1 to f2 idea and the knight from F 2
is preventing the Queen from coming to
h3 and also the knight from F 2 is
blocking this F pawn so instead after
this F captures on e3 our job of played
the immediate F 2 check so he decided to
sacrifice this pawn to open up a lines
of attack
he says he didn't really calculate it
all the way to the end but he thought I
mean this surely must be winning in some
way so capturing the pawn is forced
Brook captures we have rook captures
King characters and now rook to f8 and
it's a very nice position for you to
analyze you're white how do you defend
here black just played the rook to f8
check so what do you do here you know
feel free to pause it you know even
briefly and decide do you go back to the
Kings side or do you go to the Queen
side so for those of you who decided to
go to go to the Kings side you would not
have too much fun this game for example
if King g2 then comes Queen to f7 and
there's really no good way for you to
defend Queen to f1 checkmate you'd have
to run away and then after Queen f1
Czech Queen blocks Queen comes here King
comes up and then Bishop to e7 this will
be checkmate and and any other
variations are too aren't all that
pleasing for white so for those of you
who went King - e - congratulations you
are you are an excellent defender so
King to e2 and this was played in the
game my Carlsen Queen to h3 threatening
to capture the h2 pawn and again this
pretty much forces Queen to h1 there's
no other good move here cousin plays
Queen - h1 and now comes Bishop to e7
Bishop to e7 he wants to activate his
Bishop maybe bring it over to g5 to
maybe create some chances here an
interesting move that the engine prefers
is rook to f6 rook to f6 with the simple
idea Rock h6 and start grabbing grabbing
upon here and maybe grab on h2 and then
you know maybe maybe even force this
night to stay on c3 to defend the a to
pawn but Roger Bob doesn't go for this
he goes Bishop to e7 and now comes
Knight to e4 Knight to e4 a beautiful
place for the night guarding g5 also
pressuring c5 and unless unless a job of
can make use of this rook on f8 it
really doesn't matter he's up the
exchange
Queen to g4 check we have King to d2 and
now Queen back to h3 rajabu is
threatening Queen rook to f1 to traffic
all since Queen on 8
so Carson simply repeats king - II -
Roger Burgos age five he may maybe he
can break through on the Kings side
Bishop to b2 and now there is a threat
of Bishop captures an e5 this would be
this would be good for white so again
Queen to g4 check King to d2 and Queen
back to h3 again you can't capture of
course because then rook to f1 would
trap the Queen
so again King to e2 is repeated we have
King to g4 check King d2 and Queen back
to h3 so this is move 36 and here after
a threefold repetition cross and and
their job of plated out to a draw so a
very exciting game and another game
where Carson really had played very
precisely and he calculated precisely
that you know given up the exchange will
not be will not matter all that much in
this position because the rook simply
can't get any play and the bishop and
end the night are somewhat more active
so a very nice game by both of them are
very very nice attack by team order job
of and a very nice defense by Magnus
Carlsen so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it another lovely game from the
2013 Candace tournament we will not talk
about the standings as will show more
games from round 7 but as usual you can
check out more photos from round seven
in the description below there will be
some nice links and do check out an
article by Peter Dodgers about around 7
and I would like to thank John Weller
Peter Peter Dannenberg adjacent D
Klinger Nicholas Siebert and Farhad
Ahmed for a contribution to my channel
think a lot to really appreciate it
Farhad Ahmed actually donated money he
won in a chess tournament in his
university and it's the first tournament
chess tournament that he ever
participated in so if that's your way of
saying that my channel is you know to
some degree responsible for you winning
this tournament you know that makes me
extremely happy so thank you very much
so yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another video from round 7 of the 2013
candidates tournament thank you